heyyyyyy 42 here in all of history one
love affair stands head and shoulders
above the rest and has enchanted
everyone from Plutarch
to Shakespeare no I'm not talking about
Donald Trump and stormy Daniels Roman
politician and General Mark Antony the
anglicized version of Marcus Antoninus
was at the height of his power one of
the most powerful men in the world
staying in the ancient city of Tarsus
near the present-day coast of Turkey
Antony requested a meeting with
Cleopatra
the Fuhrer of Ptolemaic Egypt they had
met one enough a 10 years prior but the
Cleopatra who Antony would soon meet
again was not the naive inexperienced
young girl he remembered then now older
and wiser Cleopatra was far more cunning
and in command of her seductive feminine
powers than Antony could have possibly
anticipated Cleopatra was a keen
cultivator of power and had an
instinctual understanding of the
personalities and vices of men who
wielded great influence knowing that
Antony was a lover of spectacle and
wishing to see the riches of Egypt for
himself
Cleopatra orchestrators an arrival luck
would nail both of these points in one
fell swoop
driving on a giant ship powered by
enormous purple sails Cleopatra's
entrance dominated the Tarsus horizon
and harbor dressed as to goddess Venus
herself found by handsome young boys and
reclining under a radiant - gold canopy
Cleopatra did everything she could to
appear as though she was a goddess
descended from heaven to visit
she even manned her ships with beautiful
women dressed as nymphs her performance
worked as the historian Appian put it
the moment he saw her
Antony lost his head to her like a young
man but Cleopatra wasn't done determined
to ensnare Antony she continued to throw
lavish parties and displays of wealth
all whilst deploying every ounce of her
well-crafted mastery of seduction her
efforts were a success and soon both
were in the throes of a love affair they
returned to Alexandria where they were
tease one another compete over who could
throw the most lavish banquets and Dolan
or behave like young lovers they even
formed the drinking society called the
inimitable livers which was perhaps an
unintentional port together they had
twins had coins made in their image and
would travel together as Antony sought
to dominate the Mediterranean with
Antony's reckless actions causing his
military to falter but their union
wouldn't last forever with their
foolhardy actions provoking the ire of
Rome they soon found themselves trapped
in Alexandria as the wrath of the Roman
Empire descended upon them Antony sought
to meet the Roman army head-on whilst
Cleopatra began to hoard huge quantities
of riches finery and jewels much to the
anger of the greed stricken Romans yet
Cleopatra was still cunning and not
about to watch herself and her children
overrun hid herself in a tomb and sent a
letter to Antony telling him she'd
committed suicide
eh Cleopatra sought to negotiate with
the Romans to no avail and her letter to
Antony caused an unintended tragedy upon
receiving a letter Antony was said to
have stated Oh
Cleopatra I am not distressed to have
lost you for I shall straightaway join
you but I am grieved that a commander as
great as I should be found to be
inferior to a woman in
rich and with nuts he took his own life
seeing what she had done Cleopatra was
horrified and after being captured by
the Romans soon took her own life as
well their love affair had come to a
morbid end now committing suicide may
not sell the idea of falling in love but
there are actually a few benefits it has
been shown to increase happiness ease
anxiety make you look after yourself and
help you live longer falling in love
that is not suicide whilst you might not
be able to match the splendor of
Cleopatra's purple sails can you make
someone fall in love with you
well according to science you can people
meet their partners in a variety of ways
these days tadic suggests the breakdown
is typically 39 percent online 27
percent at a bar and restaurants 20
percent through friends 11 percent at
work 9 percent at school or college and
7 percent fruit family proximity is
highly conducive to romantic
entanglements in a study of over 400
soon-to-be married couples over 50% of
them lived 16 blocks or fewer away from
one another when they first dated and
nearly 40% of them were only five blocks
away however modern methods of dating
are changing as evidenced by the 39% of
those who meet their partners online
this has increased from 22 percent in
2009 conversely people meeting through
friends has fallen from 34 percent in
1990 all the way down to 20 percent
online dates it may be an appealing way
to meet a partner but don't undervalue
the importance of proximity because
according to the data if you don't live
near each other that's love is highly
unlikely to flourish its way to the
altar but what about your character does
who you are your personality wants
desires and faults have any bearing on
your ability to attract and mate
well yes of course it does but what may
surprise you is that those who
consistently get offers to fall in love
of them and have a very high frequency
of relationships
have two specific traits in common high
self-confidence and low defensiveness in
other words they're confident enough to
go after who they're interested in and
aren't too defensive to lower their
guard and connect with potential
partners on a deeper emotional level
they're comfortable making themselves
vulnerable
by contrast insecure people tend to
avoid genuine vulnerable kinds of
intimacy opting instead for a game
playing power center type of love that
helps them superficially feel secure
like the cliche of the indifferent
playboy who is really just scared of
getting hurt so what I'm saying is if
you want to get lots of people to fall
in love with you just be yourself
terrible advice I know especially if
your usual self is a sucker [ __ ]
but being fake isn't going to get you
anywhere either this whole relationship
between identity and love was brought to
the forefront by german-american
development psychologist Erik Erikson
famous for his theory on psychological
development in human beings Erikson
thought that people's identities go
through necessary changes as they
negotiate between the biological and
sociological forces in their life when
these two forces clash this causes an
identity crisis a phrase which Erikson
actually coined if an individual manages
to successfully manage this identity
crisis he emerges more fully formed and
more capable of navigating his life in a
more virtuous manner if he does not then
he carries these challenges into the
later stages of his life
for instance issues with trust
experienced in childhood to put it
simply if you have a tough childhood and
come out of it a more well-rounded and
self-confident person then you'll be
lucky in love but if it later gets the
better of you you'll be resigned to a
life of cats and ice cream Erikson
thoughts that this identity crisis
usually emerges during our 20s to late
but there are also some sneaky
techniques that you can use to generate
feelings of love in someone else
iContact is one of the most powerful
forms of communication especially when
it comes to love as Shakespeare wrote
learn to read what silent love have
ripped to hear with eyes belongs to
love's fine wit social psychologist Zig
rubin went to land to study exactly how
iContact was related to love what he
discovered was that the higher couples
rated on this scale of mutual love the
more time that they spend gazing into
one another's eyes in fact they stared
directly into one another's eyes and
only looked away reluctantly in
comparison couples who rated poorly
under love ohmmeter
spent far less time locking eyes and in
a 1989 study a group of strangers were
paired up and asked to stare into the
eyes of their new acquaintances for two
minutes traits the result was that all
participants reported romantic feelings
towards that person who they only two
minutes earlier had never seen before
there were even some marriages of the
back of this experiment what does this
mean for you
firstly you want to be able to look the
person you like in the eye as it will
help subconsciously communicate your
affection and interest and secondly if
someone is giving you clear attentive
eye contact this may be a sign he or she
is interested in you and mirroring as
eye contact may help to foster feelings
of love between the two of you also on
your first date opt for a coffee shop
over the pub Yale psychology professor
John Park discovered that when people's
bodies are warmer they behave more
warmly towards others another sneaky
brain trick is to purposely embarrass
yourself on your first date research at
Harvard Business School revealed that
79% of people prefer to date people who
are open about their mistakes rather
than attempt to cover them up and what
better way to demonstrate to someone
that you aren't hiding anything done to
exit
they spill a drink on your crotch well I
guess you could just talk more openly to
your date about your faults whoo where's
the fun in that this may seem like an
obvious one but try to make subtle
physical contact with your love interest
a study in 2006 in France showed that
women are far more likely to give their
number to a man if he touches her
forearm before her uncertainty about
one's emotions is strangely also viewed
as an attractive quality especially in
men when women were asked to rate the
attractiveness of men the men who were
unsure about whether or not they liked
the women those who kept their cards
close to their chest were consistently
ranked as the most attractive by the
women and the ostensibly desperate men
were ranked as the least attractive the
women found themselves thinking more
about these mysterious on certain men
which is why I like to refer to my
partner as the current mrs. 42 just to
keep her on her toes how can you apply
this practically in your life well don't
give the game away too much like an
eager puppy and leave some guessing in
her mind however remember that this can
backfire if you do this from a place of
self-protection game playing or the cost
of intimacy you're going against almost
everything else that science has said
works so tread carefully there are also
certain questions that have been noted
to generate feelings of love between two
people psychologists are Firmin designed
a series of questions that steadily
increase in intimacy he found that when
he studied strangers who utilized these
questions and those who did not the
strangers who did felt far greater
closeness than those who engaged in
simple small talk instead the questions
range from given the choice of anyone in
the world whom would you want as a
dinner guest to if a crystal ball could
tell you the truth about yourself your
life the future or anything else what
would you want to know
and for what in your life do you feel
most grateful
although following our own specific
questions will help to oil up the
conversation and get those love juices
flowing there is a general rule here if
you want someone's who love you don't
hang around at the shallow small talk
end of the conversational pool because
you'll never move to the deep end where
all the fun happens another powerful and
strangely overlooked technique you can
employ is to be the version of yourself
you think people will want to have sex
with science shows that being intimate
with someone floods both of your bodies
with oxytocin commonly thought to be the
love hormone in other words it's
scientifically possible to make someone
fall in love with you using sex alone
what to ensure greater success at this
commendable task you should actively try
to be someone your intended sweetheart
would want to jump between the sheets
with I know you can't just click your
fingers and become a more sexually
desirable but whilst everyone has a
different type there are some science
backed methods that will make people be
more likely to stand to attention and
take notice
these are become funnier have a more
vibrant social life connect on a deeper
level be more assertive smile more wear
red especially if you're female get a
dog especially if you're male have a
reputation for being nice and or kind
have a suave apartment become a musician
especially if you're male dress well and
lose weight put those cheekbones on show
engage in risks that emulate those faced
by hunter-gatherers such as survival and
hunting especially if you're male and
lastly have incredibly large breasts and
this one is definitely only if you're
female if you do these things I can't
guarantee that you
have sex and thus a great propensity for
love sorry but I can't definitely tell
you that science says you're more likely
to all these cheap ish techniques aside
perhaps the best thing you can do to
attract others is to simply try to
understand yourself a little better as
knowing or not knowing certain
techniques isn't going to be your
biggest roadblock to love you will be
one of the ways you can do this is to
understand what development psychologist
Mary Ainsworth called
attachment styles attachment styles
outline the basic ways we go about
forming attachments with others based on
our learned experience during childhood
she identified four of these styles one
of which is secure free of which are
insecure the insecure types are anxious
preoccupied this is when you have a low
self-worth a high dependence on others
and often an addiction to validation
through love you will often never
receive enough love as it's a band-aid
for the low opinion you have of yourself
in other words you're a stereotypical
needy person dismissive avoidant this is
where you have a low opinion of yourself
but also over people you say things like
I don't need anyone identify with cool
loners in fiction and often think you're
invulnerable to the need for intimacy
spoiler alert you're not and this is
just a fear of rejection in disguise
fearful avoidant this is where you might
actively seek out relationships but as
soon as they might start to get a little
serious you bug the hell out of ACK
jettison and abandon ship you want the
closeness but you're too afraid of the
vulnerability that comes with it so you
only go so far the secure type is called
well secure this is where you like who
you are and you like other people you
seek out closeness and you're willing to
make yourself vulnerable for it but
you're also okay when it fails or you
get rejected
it might be painful but you can handle
it these are the attachment styles
although God knows what Cleopatra was
suicidal drinker perhaps when you
understand your attachment style or more
specifically your relationship with
intimacy you will hopefully get a better
handle on what is your largest roadblock
to making someone love you perhaps it's
simply your own fear of being gloved but
until that happens just invest in a dog
and let it do the seducing for you it's
much easier thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video then please consider
supporting me on patreon because it
really helps me to continue to make them
you can find a link in the description
below also you can get your hands on a
first edition signed copy of my new book
sticker flagging it by heading on over
to unbound publishing and pre-ordering
your copy today the links in the
description thank you